OK, let's jump into audience questions for
the week.
The first is, hey, David, how likely is violence
after the November election?
So there's a few different aspects to this
question that you're not clarifying violence
against or by which group.
And I think there's a few different scenarios
that could lead to violence.
Now, the most likely scenario that leads to
violence is Trump claims it was rigged and
his supporters take to the streets with guns.
That would be the top like red alert violence
possibility in my mind.
Are there scenarios in which so, you know,
there are right wingers who seem to be suggesting
that if Trump gets reelected, the left is
going to become so out of control, furious
that the left will start rioting and burning
things to the ground and looting and and and
all of this stuff.
That's not really what I'm afraid of.
I think that if Donald Trump were to get reelected,
there will be it'll sort of be a 50/50 effect.
Some people, much like when Trump was first
elected in November of 2016, will be outraged
and will take to the streets.
And as you remember, from November of 2016,
those were widely peaceful protests.
November, December 26.
I don't even remember incidents, you know,
nationwide protests, hundreds and hundreds
of thousands of people protesting.
And, you know, you could try find some news
story of some anecdote, but it was not part
of the narrative.
Very different than the narrative that the
right created around the George Floyd protests.
So some people on the left, certainly if Trump
is reelected, they will be out there protesting.
But there's also going to be a lot of people
on the left who were just totally deflated.
And I expect a portion of the left will check
out of politics for maybe not for years, but
certainly until the 2022 midterm.
And then we'll get involved in the 2024 election
relatively late because it will be.
I mean, listen, I understand I've said before,
Trump is better for my business, but he's
terrible for the country.
And so I am fine with my business not doing
as well.
If it's good for the country, but if it's
another four years of Trump, it is good.
I'm going to certainly be deflated.
And I know there are lots of people on the
left who will be as well.
And I would not be shocked for a bunch of
those people to check out.
So I don't believe there's a real risk of
violence if Trump wins.
Now, if Trump loses, there's a couple different
scenarios there as Trump loses by an insane
margin, like electorally, it's a huge margin
and popular vote.
I don't think that the right is likely to
become too violent in that case.
Trump could claim it's obviously rigged because
I never would have lost by this much.
But I think the truth is that if both the
popular vote and the electoral vote are big
margins for Biden, I think that by and large,
the Trump ists will just say, wow, we just
lost.
And they will essentially disappear for some
period of time.
I don't think they're likely to be violent
in that case.
I think the two scenarios for violence would
be big popular vote win, but it's really tight
electorally.
And Trump loses by just like one or two states
and claims it's wrecked.
I think that scenario could certainly lead
to violence.
And then I think the one that is most likely
to lead to Trump is out in the streets.
Is that everything is close and Trump loses
both electorally and popular vote and says
it was rigged.
And that's the one where I would worry about,
you know, the so-called gun people that Donald
Trump has referred to going out there and
doing some some some horrible things.
I believe it will be relatively short lived
if and when it becomes clear that Trump just
lost and no secretary of state is going to
save him and that even if he could file some
lawsuit to get a recount or even flip one
state, that that it won't be enough in the
scenario where it's a bigger victory for Joe
Biden, if indeed that happens.
I think that the violence will be quelled
relatively quickly and by inauguration time,
I believe it will essentially be over.
Now, whether we see more radical extremists
activated if Trump is removed.
That's a fair question, which I'd have to
think about a little more.
But I think that the most likely scenario
for violence is a Trump loss.
That is not a major loss, that it's close.
And Trump claims it's rigged, maybe refuses
to concede and continues to argue that either
vote by mail went wrong or something like
that.
That's the scenario that to me lends itself
most to violence in the streets.
And I hope that authorities will be ready
and prepared to.
With that.